I argue that there's there's nothing
that's better than the forbidden fruit
of hurting kids please explain the
juiciest of fruits right it's the fruit
that you bite into it keeps giving and
there's this juice all over
[Music]
anybody here a fan of dodgeball not the
movie just the sport yeah absolutely I
guess we all enjoyed it when we were
here hell yeah all right best part it's
great for kids to play dodgeball
honestly I think so too I think it's
such a fun sport but I remember a fourth
grade no I was like yes I'm Gonna Be
Fifth Grade next year because our
playground didn't allow fourth graders
to play what to gangster
or too rough well it's probably because
the fifth and sixth graders were [__]
up the fourth graders yeah the fifth
graders abandoned our our school are
they bad really yeah because exactly
exactly because of that well you guys
playing dodgeball with bowling balls or
something you know the the rubber ones
which they don't use anymore they use
those the styrofoam ones I know the
rubber ones hurt dude imagine this guy's
throwing a ball at your face [__] people
will [__] launch it you know yeah
it's so satisfying the sound of it going
would it hit somebody I mean and then
their glasses fall off and they're
crying the technique is you wait till
they jump and then you hit their legs
and then they fall then they get a
concussion yeah the technique the
technique is to put it in dog [__]
[__] Ryan dude Ryan's the worst you
should throw it back in the court and
then leave because there's collateral
damage all right well dodgeball has
become the center of controversy at an
elementary school uh because the there's
a teacher who has been charged with
misdemeanor assault and battery oh come
on after being accused of hitting a kid
with a dodgeball he's a legend wait was
he playing with them and just [__]
launching at them
um it's uh he said she said that there's
two sides of the story here that's fun
being a full-grown adult and you got
little targets everywhere no dude that's
great
I know the rule of the world at that
point yeah you really are so according
to court documents a student went to the
principal at Carriage Hills after the
man allegedly hit them three times once
in the back once in the leg and once in
the face which knocks their glasses off
dude it's not funny but it's funny dude
that's extra points wait was he already
out is that why this is bad because
that's funny
already yeah
walking away from the field he's on the
sidelines come on don't be a [__]
Gotta Keep Your Eyes up I I argue that
there's
not there is nothing that's better than
the forbidden fruit of hurting kids
but like in a
airplane yeah juiciest fruits right it's
the fruit that you bite into it keeps
giving and there's just juice all over I
think the the Dalai Lama
but you're not allowed to
out to the game and this is an accident
we went to uh
uh like a Sky Zone which is like a
trampoline park so type is just bouncing
on the trampoline by himself and I was
like I'm gonna jump next to him and see
what would happen oh no run I jumped and
this dude was like in the air and you
see his eyes
oh [__] and then when he landed he
landed all weird he didn't break
anything but he started crying of course
my my brain or he would know because
he's a physiologist my physiology was
confused because it was half happiness
and half sadness you know
my endorphins were taking over my body
in my mind how did you feel man dude
that's a funny extra dopamine
you're not out until your glasses fall
off that's great oh yeah so the student
here again there's two sides of this
story the student told police that they
had thrown a dodgeball while playing a
game when it bounced off another student
and then it hit this employee all right
the employee then allegedly got mad
which led to the student getting hit
with the ball kids are kids already lie
you can tell the student went to the
principal told her what happened and
several other kids also told the
principal the same story nah you can
tell the kids are like that's a huge lie
he said so obviously what happened is a
kid thought it'd be funny to throw it at
an employee randomly to piss him off and
then he but he's really saying it's a
Ricochet no kid is throwing that hard
that the Ricochet is gonna offend you
out those types of balls yeah but even
several other kids backing you up hey
that's you work together playground lob
yeah right that's true [__] that guy
here's the other side
when interviewed by police the employee
said he was sitting in the class and the
student threw the ball at him and
another teacher and wouldn't apologize
there you go sounds pretty proud the
teacher said that that yeah the employee
they say they keep saying employee but
uh for I guess for a technical term it's
important he said he hit the student
with the ball and asked if he should
apologize for doing that and the kid
said yes he said he told the kid that
was how he and the other teacher felt
that's his side just some brats bro
that's it yeah but should he actually
get in trouble for it or assault I feel
like they should beat the [__] out of
those kids
how old are these kids it's Elementary
School
exactly they should do a firing squad
with dodgeballs yeah yeah on the kids
yeah you get two of the three you want
to punish the kids yeah yeah just just
teach them a lesson you can't be
throwing dodgeballs at people so then
they gotta line up isn't that the whole
entire point of dodgeball throwing not
random bystanders yeah it's in the game
but they have to figure out who's
telling you the truth first yeah how do
you do that you line them all up how do
you get the truth out of a kid
you know how to do it especially if
they're all coming for each other you
punish everybody someone's gonna rap oh
yeah that's always how it happens or
tickle them all right you're gonna run
15 laps every day until somebody says
the truth the nerdiest kid they're like
I I gotta do my homework yeah that was
me yeah
[Laughter]
I gotta get to this
but they don't do that anymore either I
heard I heard they released like why
stop doing blanket punishments that's
[__] up yeah that's how you pull out
the bad guys I know it was an angel what
discipline is a loud node nothing you
gotta talk to the parent or something I
think kids get away with a lot these
days just with like really saw the legal
stuff that can happen just a parent
kicking up some [__] you guys probably
did a second on this I don't even know
but the [__] litter box [__] oh
yeah we saw that what was the litter box
one the kid identified as a cat and they
didn't put a litter box in the [__]
room so the parents tried to sue the
teacher or some [__] it's like humans
poop in toilets man is it here in
California isn't likely I'm just sorry
California you guys you suck sometimes
not wrong not wrong
I'm gonna go the polar opposite and
maybe I'll make a school that's called
like 1950. oh oh God it's just cool it's
called 1950 yeah and the male teacher
just whipping on the female teachers
there's gonna be a civil rights movement
post segregation fully segregated right
no California rules California rules
can we drink from the same fountains or
no the California rules different doors
different bathrooms our budget has been
the piping is gonna be tricky let me
tell you that I would not have survived
back then I only dated the black girls
from my high school I'm like no I can't
have no we're gonna drink from the same
Fountain she's coming with me it's
happening you would have fought for them
absolutely a beautiful black woman every
year that has to happen too segregation
gets broken every year like exactly like
the year went I gotta say uh I'm one of
those people who maybe it's because I
was disciplined as well as a kid going
on when I say discipline explicitly it's
like you get beat by your parents or
mainly your dad right just straight up
dad beating right yeah step dad comes
home drunk he punches you in the face I
get it
me
leave in at least a boy growing up he
needs to understand that there are
consequences to actions yeah hell yeah
like or else we're gonna grow up to be
like yeah absolute gangsters yeah but I
but I know that there's many people
especially in today's age that believe
any type of physical violence like that
is off the table that's not the
inappropriate way I think it's because
they grew up where their parents were
just way too crazy so it's like
there are certain levels I believe of
like how you control violence with you
know physical punishment but then some
parents are like just absolute like dogs
like they're just psychos they're just
drunk and crazy and they'll [__] you up
too hard there's no lesson behind that
no they're just I just want to [__] you
up you're just random yeah some of them
like I remember when I one of my worst
ass beatings it was in kindergarten and
I was at the desk and uh like I was had
trouble keeping all the pens on the desk
for some reason kept falling off
Cuts apart
[__] [__] and I remember stay on my
desk I remember my dad picking me up
slamming me on the ground pulling down
my house it started wailing on my ass my
grandpa comes and like tell him to stop
and you can tell them to get out of the
room and it just kept going and then
like as I got older I was like what's
the lesson and I think what it was is he
was just probably trying to sleep and he
was just so [__] pissed that I was
making sounds so he just took it out on
me he's like shut up yeah yeah Square
pencils now that's the lesson I know
that if we still cut to that Family Guy
in you know insert young bars taking
these [__] pens and chucking it at
his dad
he's like I love drumming he goes I'm
gonna make this one bounce yeah
yeah it's probably like you're making
yourself like I love Lucy episode it's
like I don't know why the pins keep
falling off the desk falling off yeah I
don't know what happened it's so weird
you no one has that problem it just I
couldn't keep them it's not a real
problem but try to explain it to
yourself one more time that's not a real
problem
back to the kids lying thing right you
still believe he's convinced his grown
up so that sounds like a bad infomercial
like you having trouble keeping pants on
the desk buy this what if I lived on one
of those gravity hills you know I just
kept rolling down everything likes to
tell your dad what the [__] is Gravity
Hill isn't that just a hill no it's like
it's like those railroad crossings where
a school bus got hit right and there's
like ghosts pushing everything you put
flour on your car there's hand prints on
it you're like Daddy stop being it's the
pen it's moving it's a neutral that's in
San Antonio they have one out here at
ghost track yeah yeah those tracks They
have a couple of them yeah there's no
one in San Antonio too and it's all the
art of perspective dude it's really
downhill problem that's hilarious I
think I think guys need to get their
asses beat though because like
statistically
um guys that grew up in a in a in a in a
like two parent household right like Dad
and Mom or single dad they're very less
likely to go to prison but single
mothers
no no their life yeah they're less
likely to go to prison but single
mothers are more likely to go to prison
oh [__] because you know Dad's a little
bit beat their [__] ass boys yeah
that's rough ending dads don't I mean
yeah girls get you know beat up too but
not as [__] hard as guys like
stereotypically but how do you regulate
when and how much to be uh how to
regularly sometimes they get beat up too
much and they turn into Psychopaths I
think even pens are [__] flying off
your ass
[Applause]
almost a little too hard this
[Music]